oh
don't tell me that camera is so ideal
how do they do that it seems impossible
to me the black hole and they actually
built a rendering engine
just for this can you guess why
what's up guys welcome back to vfx
artists react and today is a very
special day because we have a very
special guest the blender guru himself
hey everybody
my name is andrew price i'm from
australia i've been using 3d software
for about 12 years my channel is called
blenderguru big fan of the show happy to
start reacting let's do it
i like the movie i've been wanting to
talk about the lego movie so beautiful i
feel like i can just touch every piece
is every lego piece like an official
lego piece in this movie yeah yeah
that's the thing that it was consist
every little piece is consistent all the
colors are actually the real colors that
they can print at the lego factory as
well honestly like this movie kind of
put the nail in the coffin of
stop-motion movies it's like when your
animation looks this real because this
is indistinguishable from like reality
stop-motion it's so detailed
yeah yeah so something about this movie
makes the lighting
way more realistic than has previously
been done in animated movies can you
guess why
read it practically and then deep fake
so the reason that this looks so
realistic
is because the lego movie was the first
major animated movie to use
the aces color and coding system a like
cheap compact camera has dynamic range
of about
11 f-stops right a dslr has about 13
f-stops and the re-alexa which is the
best camera has 14.5 f-stops the best
device is actually
your eye which has 20 f-stops previous
animated movies couldn't do something
like this because if they exposed for
the sun then everything else would fall
into darkness they were reducing the
power of the sunlight because they
needed to expose for everything else
just like the sun would have to be
forced into that
exactly yeah which doesn't make any
sense so what they did is they switched
it to aces which allowed them to use an
f-stop of up to 30. so they went from
five f-stops to 30. in this scene we
have in the background we have some some
people having coffee in a shadow and we
can still see the detail we can see that
he's wearing glasses we can see the
color of his hair and as well as that we
have extremely bright sunlight which is
hitting those coffee cups bouncing off
his head there and that is the real
value of the sun relative to everything
else right by having this at the correct
thing they can actually have like the
real values that look and feel that way
it can actually capture the full color
spectrum as well so it's not just high
damage range it's a wide color gamut but
what's interesting is how that applies
at certain exposure ranges when
something is overexposed the colors
desaturate as things get brighter and
previously they weren't doing that when
you turn it on for a 3d scene it's just
like everything works the way it should
the the light is the correct value
things are washing out as they should
you can actually use the true value of
light as it should be there's a couple
other really subtle things that all play
together to make this stuff look really
photorealistic one is when you're
filming stuff in miniature your depth of
field gets really really shallow because
imagine taking a telephoto lens and
zooming in on something that's only this
big if you shot this in real life like a
wide angle lens like a 28 millimeter
lens of a real person on the couch you
wouldn't have that shallow of the depth
of field but if you shot a miniature you
would so they're actually mimicking the
real life
parameter light wrap and light bloom and
hdri but the other huge thing was the
imperfections you could even see like
the seam line when he was like uh
shaving you could see the seam line in
his hair like the details that's so cool
i can feel my fingernail running over
the top of it yeah exactly the lego
movie i think it was very successful
because it made me want to play with my
legos
after watching it
is a good one watch your head boy oh no
don't get dragged into the mist this guy
looks way too chill for like what's
going on frank castle what's his name
i mean is that the punisher
[Laughter]
the great the practical effects are
totally like
wow upselling the visual effects yeah
exactly oh man
you know he's gone just let him go right
mama oh yeah so this is
that looks a little rough never seen
again see like they don't ah the thing
they don't look that i hate that that
that does not look good to me i think
part of it is the texturing is
unmotivated yeah like that like it looks
kind of like just a uniform like they
got what's the net like not a
caterpillar what's the one that's like
oh a worm or a centipede in australia we
have them witchity grubs which is babies
oh it looks like you've got rubbish
oh yeah yeah yeah it's a real thing a
witchy grub and it reminds me of that
and it's just kind of like this it's got
like little blood vessels going through
it but it's like the actual creature
itself has got like bones and like
things in it so it should have like in
my opinion like parts that are clean and
then other parts that are like more
fleshy it's all one texture it's all
uniformly slimy another thing i'm
noticing there is that the lighting is
also a little bit of that like
weird movie lighting if you look at the
character in the front yeah like his
face the side of his face is really
bright but the other side of his head is
basically black same with the guy's
baseball cap but that worm the left side
of it isn't black it's still kind of a
glowing
medium dark gray i feel like this is
something that's kind of a director's
fault probably the artist lights it with
accurate lighting the scene the director
goes you know what it's too dark add
some more lights and the vfx artist goes
like but you didn't have lights there on
set and the director goes i don't care i
can't see it make it brighter and then
now suddenly the cg object is just not
really lit correctly look at the
lighting game look at the lighting on
his face and look at the lighting on the
tentacle oh yeah the tentacle's just
uniformly lit and his face is very
clearly dark on one side where's this
edge light coming from
yeah you see that edge light right there
yeah like well you don't see the edge
light on frank castle over here you know
one last thing to point out one of the
most challenging things you can ever
give to a compositor
it's a shot with smoke and you say
please put the cg object in the middle
of this smoke imagine for a minute that
i'll give you a picture of clint and i
gave you a picture of the grand canyon
and i asked you to cut clint out and put
him in the grand canyon oh and for extra
realism here's a bush to put in front of
clint like okay great i'm gonna need an
x-acto knife and a couple hours to cut
out that bush but i can do it and it
looks alright now let's say i have a
picture of a wisp of smoke i say i want
you to cut this out and put that over
clint how do you cut out a whisk with
smoke like sure there might be defined
edges but the smoke's transparent that's
the challenge you're facing when you're
trying to cut out smoke and put it over
a cg object but they're having to do
fake smoke on top of that real smoke for
the tentacles to blend them in and then
you end up with a non-looking real shot
right so the the director i think it was
frank darabont who directed this he
actually released the black and white
version of this movie and apparently
that's the way to watch this movie
is the black and white version it
probably helps tie in the cg a lot
better
oh what's this
panic room
2002
wait till the camera can't fit through
those banisters how did he do it how did
he do it
oh they're still good i'm not done yet
he's still going
don't tell me that camera's not funny
again
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
just like the trench run but for cameras
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god he's
we ain't done yet he's still going dude
he's soloing so hard
[Music]
whoa that's amazing whoa
he didn't need to do this right yeah
like you could just have a regular cut
you could just have regular cuts well it
really gives you a sense of the space
which you need to have for a piece
that's about space
and it's also a real time breakdown of
what is actually happening so it puts
you in the vibe of these characters who
are hiding from these guys so can you
guys guess which parts are cg those
railings are probably cg so they just
didn't have the railing there i think
everything is probably a hidden cut here
it's easy oh the door
banister's for sure definitely the best
yeah banister's definitely look all
right
what i tell you guys what i tell you
guys i think it's full green screen on
this window here
i think so
yes look at this green screen that's
crazy here comes the green screen
you're gonna wipe it it's not green
we're gonna wipe with the green
background
it's not great
because you don't see the camera in the
reflection either yeah that's an
entirely thicker oh i didn't even notice
that hit me with that 3d camera
everything
cg wow hats off to uh david fincher's
team on this one man that's
masterclass
this is okay this is like right
alongside with the lego movie in terms
of i feel like i can touch it okay
interesting because they were also at
around the same time this was when asus
was happening and they were one of the
first people to try aces that's what's
up yeah look at that look how embedded
that is in the frame it's it's there the
handoff did you guys notice the handoff
no what was that he handed him a knife
is that guy holding a cg knife or
is it a real knife that the actor
actually because they they use charlton
comply right
shoutout copley was actually in the
scene from what i've gathered they just
kind of filmed it and they're just like
alright vfx artist you figure it out
one of the guys that worked on the film
emailed us and everything was hand
tracked
artists had to go in there and by hand
just line up their skeleton rig with
what his motions were and just eyeball
it and they did such a good job the
other thing is all the paint outs like
same deal like they're sitting there
rebuilding a bunch of the background and
a bunch of different elements because
you have to remove a human being from
the shot first before you can put a
robot back into it that is the hardest
part yes is painting out the background
i heard there are artists that would
work on one shot for like three to four
months just you get that one shot and
for the next like summer that's the only
thing you work on painting out ninja's
chest chappie's hand is going across
ninja's chest so originally charlotte
copley was probably reaching out and
grabbing the knife meaning they had to
rebuild that part of his chest so that
they can erase charlotte copeland's hand
and put a robot hand there
oh what a nightmare and you can't tell
how do they do that it's super time
consuming work it's just painful
watching watching this man getting
flashbacks to this
yeah so so what do you guys think they
did uh that that helped it look as good
as it as it does we had to replicate
this with which arguably we kind of did
with the boston dynamics video the way
you do it is this real reference for the
motion real actor on set interacting
with people so people like eye lines
match and motions match and rhythms
match getting actual light samples from
set aka getting a 360 degree hdri of the
set if your cg is built in a photo
realistic manner that should all come
together and give you a rather
photorealistic looking end product
apparently what they did was they
started with the cg model then they sent
the parts off for printing 3d printing
and then they sent those to weta and
weta actually built scale practical
models of chappie and they built 11 of
them in different damage states
obviously he's moving so they didn't use
that in the film but they used it as
reference and so the lighting was
actually they had something to compare
it against that's that's amazing so like
in in the mist they probably didn't have
reference of a tentacle thingy
but here they have reference of a robot
and you can actually match it one to one
if you can match them up it's gonna look
perfect if they couldn't build it and it
wouldn't function in real life and that
means you're dealing with something
that's impossible and couldn't actually
work so it also helps it feel authentic
yes yes
the black hole interstellar here we go
this this shot that's crazy like on imax
was like
interstellar is actually one of our most
requested videos in the comments so i'm
glad we're finally getting to it and if
you have any scenes shows whatever you
would like us to react to please do
leave a comment we read them they're
great inspiration there's like a
difference between the david fincher
effect or chappie where it's like oh
that's something that i know and yeah
versus this which is like
it's it's beyond us right no one has
seen something like this you can see it
wobble right there
yeah so it's a physical model right yeah
that's the model the reflections in the
window perfect a black hole you can't
photograph it right because it's a black
hole yeah there's no light
there's nothing there right it's
literally just a
the like super massive gravity which
everything is sucked into so how would
you possibly depict that on film there's
the concept of an accretion disk the
power of the gravity is so
amazing that basically it's sucking like
a universe around it so this is an
accretion disk now the reason that
you're getting this halo effect there
it's kind of interesting so for this
instead of starting with an artist
concept which is what they would
typically do right they actually started
with a physicist and they said hey tell
us how black holes work throw some mass
at us they gave that math to the render
engine guys and they actually built a
rendering engine
just for this wow and what happened was
they had this accretion this they had
the thing on it and then they saw this
weird halo effect and they go it must be
a bug
this isn't this isn't right and then
they showed it to kip and then he went
oh of course
and what you're actually seeing is what
would physically happen because they
typed in numbers yeah hit enter and got
that yeah and it surprised everyone
because
physically that would actually would
happen with increasing this so you're
seeing that same accretion disk like a
saturn ring but you're seeing the other
side of the black hole it's it's
reflecting around it which is like so
like the black hole's gravity is so
intense it's basically lensing the light
from the other side and like pulling it
up and around the black hole that's
insane that that is math and i'm sure
they came in
and like added some clouds and some cool
particles and they tweaked it up a
little bit but
that's that's amazing they actually got
two research papers out of this really
yeah it actually like they contributed
to the scientific community isn't that
crazy that's awesome a hollywood movie
we'll have to come back to interstellar
again to talk about uh the robot
so subscribe if you want to see that i
loved your insight on the lego movie and
a lot of these other like 3d things that
you brought to the table uh is that just
all from your guru learning ah
nice if you want to learn 3d if you're
watching this and you're like hey maybe
i have a career in vfx waiting for me
come to blenderguru you'll learn how to
make a donut i have multiple friends
i've done that donut tutorial yeah yeah
it's free guys like blenders portals are
free and blender is free yeah zero yet
barrier to entry anyone with a
connection it works on everything so
yeah thank you guys for your suggestions
and please leave some more also we have
a subreddit our slash corridor we all go
there all the time so if you ever want
to talk to us a little bit more closely
than like say the watch of youtube here
consider hitting on over there there's a
link in the description below i'm so
happy that we get to
share our passions with you and turn
more people on to what's honestly such
an essential part of filmmaking but
often kind of just gets left behind the
curtain consider subscribing if you
haven't already or if you don't miss a
single video ring that bell bye
[Music]